none of this story two brothers are
being questioned as persons of interest
in the alleged beating of empire star
Jesse Smollett their Chicago home was
raided yesterday now a source tells CBS
Chicago station wbbm-tv that
investigators want to know where the men
help the actor staged the incident
Chicago Police tweeted that reports
about the incident being a hoax are
unconfirmed by case detectives Dean
Reynolds is outside Chicago Police
Headquarters and has covered this from
the beginning Dean good morning good
morning well the two brothers are of
Nigerian descent and they apparently
left for Nigeria on the same day that
this alleged attack occurred upon their
return to Chicago they were detained at
O'Hare Airport by police who wanted to
question them and now their attorney
says they could face charges later today
though what charges those could be is
still unclear they're baffled why they
are people of interest attorney Gloria
Schmidt says her clients are adamant
they had nothing to do with the alleged
attack on Empire star
jussie Smollett it's an awful thing what
happened to Jesse but it's not my guys
Schmidt says her clients have worked
with small that on the set of Empire and
have spent time with him at the gym she
says they were as shocked as everyone
else when they learned about the
possible hate crime this is someone that
they know this is someone that they've
worked with so they don't want to see
somebody go through that last month
Smollett told police two men beat him
around 2:00 a.m. near his Chicago
apartment police later released these
two surveillance images of the persons
of interest
Smollett who is openly gay told police
the attackers doused him with an unknown
substance that smelled like bleach and
tied a rope around his neck he detailed
the alleged attack in a recent interview
I see
the attacker masked and he said this
maggot country punches me right in the
face so I stood back and then we started
tussling there was a second person
involved who was kicking me in my back
police raided the Chicago home of the
persons of interest Thursday doors were
broken and closed and belongings tossed
around CBS Chicago Station wbbm-tv
reports police removed bleach a black
face mask at a Red Hat an empire script
receipts and other items I've never been
some media [ __ ] that's not who I am I
don't look for that type of attention
small ad has denied being involved or
making up the assault he said he's
hopeful the attackers will be found now
20th Century Fox is disputing reports
that Smollett was being written out of
the show Empire at the time all of this
went down his publicist says that
Smollett went in for a routine round of
follow-up questioning by police
detectives yesterday and he continues to
cooperate viana story just becomes more
and more confusing dean thank you